[Music]
everyone has heard the stories about
what happened back in 68 the most brutal
series of occult murders in wyoming
history
ten victims killed over a series of four
months found with their hearts cut out
near some old cabin out in the sticks
all these innocent people's lives were
cut short in the service of worshiping
some entity that nobody else understood
thankfully the murders had stopped by
the start of the 70s and this humble
wyoming county knew nothing but peace
for several years after but the cabin
where it all happened remained abandoned
the ground was sour there weighed down
by the horrors that transpired you need
to be brave or foolish to set foot there
all things considered that's what led 17
year old charlie and his reluctant
girlfriend samantha to that rickety old
building one cold dark winter night he
was doing what most foolhardy teenage
boys tried to do with almost every
action they took
prove himself
samantha was just along for the ride
despite her protests her folks had
always warned her about this place the
word they most often used to describe it
was
evil
but charlie wouldn't take no for an
answer he was going to open that rickety
front door and step inside and samantha
would watch in awe of his bravery though
as he got closer and felt his fingers
nearing the door handle a pang of fear
tingled through him was this really
something he wanted to do too late to
back out now
samantha was watching he couldn't be a
coward he needed to commit he needed to
prove he could do this charlie took a
final deep breath
opened the door and stepped through into
the dark he would never be seen again
samantha squinted and looked into the
dark there was no into really it was
like a giant black rectangle was
obscuring the doorway there was no way
to make out any of the features inside
she called her boyfriend's name with a
quivering voice and got nothing in
response that's when she should have
started running it might have even saved
her a figure emerged from the door
walking fast it was solid black with no
discernible features only a vaguely
humanoid shape it walked towards her
with such speed and purpose that poor
samantha didn't even have time to scream
the creature extended a clawed hand and
reached through her chest it didn't even
break the skin
just face through her skin muscle and
bone like a ghost passing through a wall
suddenly she felt immense pain as the
creature drew back its hand it was
holding something that moved and
squirmed in its clawed grip it was only
as samantha collapsed her vision going
dark for the last time that she realized
she was looking at her own beating heart
and this wouldn't be where the horrors
ended for this little wyoming town
now this was only the beginning
more people would go missing in the
following days and weeks wildlife and
livestock would also be found dead under
mysterious circumstances local vets were
baffled by dead pets found in yards with
no obvious cause of death only to be
confused and horrified when they
performed an autopsy and found massive
internal bleeding and a missing heart
despite the fact that there was never
any kind of wound indicating a heart's
removal your average weird occult
murders are the fbi's problem but when
hearts start to disappear in a
mysterious fashion that's how the scp
foundation gets involved in your case
they dispatched a number of field agents
into the town in order to track down the
source of this anomalous activity and
potentially secure and contain whatever
hostile entity was behind it in this
case they really didn't need to track
the entity down
it came for them
three agents were driving down a lonely
wyoming road near the cabin when a
sudden series of shapes glowed into
prominence in the car's high beams it
wasn't just one of those vantablack
creatures
it was several the second the car ground
to a halt the entities engaged with
extreme hostility they attacked
seemingly unaffected by conventional
arms fire from the two agents in the
front seats they dragged them out of the
car before reaching into their chests
and pulling out their hearts the agent
in the back seat got lucky he'd had
experience with being similar to this in
the past and had one method that might
work as they drew towards him he loaded
a magazine of silver-tipped rounds into
his handgun closer closer the agent also
happened to be a devout muslim and as
the creatures approached he drew his
weapon and prayed to allah for the
strength to overcome these demons he
opened fire just as they were climbing
into the car and reaching for him for
the first time the bullets seemed to
have an effect the creatures squealed as
the gunfire rendered through them the
one stealth fatal wounds briefly
convulsed before melting into a fine
sulphuric sludge the agent thinking on
his feet noticed that the creatures that
stole the hearts of his two fellow
agents were fleeing he followed them
trying to find their source
and of course it was the cabin the
creatures passed back through the open
door into the darkness of the cabin how
many of them were there and what was
going on inside naturally the full mind
of the scp foundation rolled into town
not long after this incident knowing now
that the cabin designated
scp-1983-1 was the source of the
creatures designated scp-1983-2
things were easier to get under control
a fake chemical plant was built around
the cabin as the pretense to keep it
contained this plant became known as
outpost 54. on-site researchers would
sleep in the facility soldiers required
for the regular culling of 1983-2
instances would make their home in the
barracks and of course there was also a
large armory filled with the specialized
weaponry and ammunition required to put
the rampaging heart stealing creatures
down
the fateful encounter that the surviving
agent had with these aggressive entities
provided the foundation with an
invaluable piece of data on how to
combat scp-1983
for reasons not fully understood the
1983-2 creatures have an extreme
reaction against sincere human belief it
doesn't matter which religion you
personally follow if you are a true
believer and you make a prayer to your
deity of choice while firing on one of
these monsters with silver-based
ammunition you will be able to slay them
brings a whole new meaning to the phrase
spray and pray
but the belief must be truly sincere for
the attack to work if there is doubt or
skepticism in your heart when you're
praying and firing well let's just say
it won't be your heart for much longer
these very particular killing methods
are the reason that mtf kai 13 also
known as the choir boys were brought in
to be the personal stewards of 1983's
containment they're a mobile task force
formed entirely of devout religious
believers whose faith guards them
against the influence of a number of
occult monsters
scp-1983 included the foundation
performed a series of cursory tests on
the cabin itself the building contained
several frustrating spatial anomalies
with the locus of these being the front
door and the living room behind it the
living room seemed impossible to access
by any means other than the anomalous
aperture in the front door any attempts
to enter it via the wall or other doors
in the house simply caused the
researchers to pop up in different areas
of the house
after a barrage of tests including
busting holes in the exterior walls in
an attempt to enter two no avail of
course the o5 council forbade further
testing it simply wasn't worth
potentially creating more openings that
1983-2 instances could emerge from
this left only one option
launching excursions into the heart of
the anomaly itself via the portal in the
front door
this seemed to be the only way to
successfully gather intel about the
inner workings for the first of three
fateful incidents a detachment from the
choir boys armed with silver munitions
were sent into the portal none of them
ever returned but for the first time in
years the front door mysteriously closed
again this led to a drastic reduction in
the release of scp-1983-2
instances but still left a whole team
potentially stranded inside a second
detachment from the choir boys was
prepared to head in and if not rescue at
least find out what happened to the
first they opened the door and ventured
inside only for history to repeat itself
not one of them would ever be seen alive
again
and what's more with the door once again
open another one of the entities soon
charged out and began attacking more
foundation researchers the onslaught
stopped only with the brave sacrifice of
agent morris a field agent stationed at
outpost 54 at the time he entered the
doorway and closed the door once again
from the inside just like everyone else
agent morris was sadly never seen alive
again but on may 23 1989
something remarkable happened having
wasted too many agents on this anomaly
already the foundation decided to send
in a d-class the d-class in question was
jackson parker a man whose personnel
file indicated that he had a profound
belief in the moral fairness of the
universe that everything that happened
simply must have happened for a reason
even his own incarceration he was given
a camera with a live feed and a lifeline
leading back outside before practically
being pushed into the cabin moments
later the lifeline was pulled taut and
snapped the feed cut off at around the
same time foundation researchers at the
outpost side having lost another guinea
pig little did they know jackson parker
wasn't dead and what's more he was about
to do what no agent of the scp
foundation could destroy scp-1983
on the inside jackson was met with a
nightmare this anomaly was so much worse
than anyone knew it didn't look like the
inside of a cabin it was a surreal
shadow dimension looking like a
patchwork amalgamation of so many
different buildings
hospitals schools offices homes
factories military installations
jackson even recognized the dingy
basement of his childhood home among the
chaos at that moment it was clear
this wasn't just one anomalous location
it was the nexus point for many how many
doors were there out there in how many
different buildings unleashing the
horrors of
scp-1983 across the world
across dimensions even lucky for jackson
he was about to receive a little help
from beyond the grave one of the choir
boys agent barclay had written a note
before he died here he gave the few
pieces of information jackson needed not
only to survive but potentially even
destroy this thing once and for all
first that the entities born from the
shadows are weaker in the dark light
gives them form in the dark they're
intangible second there is no way out
through the front door if someone tries
to escape outside their body will melt
almost instantaneously
and most importantly of all agent
barkley realized why they'd been taking
the hearts in the center of this
terrible place lies the nest a giant
pile of human hearts surrounded by light
sources acting as a kind of incubator
after being placed in the nest the
hearts burst open and new instances of
scp-1983-2 emerge if someone could
destroy the nest it may destroy the very
heart of scp-1983
and finally neutralized this nightmarish
anomaly agent barkley had lost his faith
seeing his friends slaughtered around
him so he didn't have it in himself to
finish this thing it could only be
jackson now and as you know jackson had
an unshakable belief that everything
happens for a reason perhaps the reason
he was here was to finally bring an end
to the suffering and that's exactly what
he was going to do
jackson shouldered barclay's rifle and
charged through the labyrinth gunning
down attacking scp-1983-2
entities on the way he was a man on a
mission soon he made his way into the
central chamber and finally saw it the
nest this horrifying pile of wriggling
human hearts one of the many sights that
finally broke agent barclay but jackson
stood unbroken he aimed the rifle at the
nest and opened fire the sheer force of
his unshakable belief supercharging his
every shot he had struck a killing blow
at the heart of the beast avenging
everyone it had ever murdered on the
outside to everyone's amazement
scp-1983 disappeared the front door
opened and the darkness dissipated
within when agents and researchers
entered they found the desiccated corpse
of several mobile task force members but
all signs of the previous anomaly were
gone from the same note left on the
corpse of agent barclay it was clear to
researchers that jackson parker had
taken the advice
and finally neutralized this dangerous
ketter class anomaly though jackson
himself was nowhere to be found he was
given a posthumous medal of bravery and
merit by the foundation only one of two
ever awarded to a d-class
i guess you could say that everything
happens for a reason now go check out
scp-3999 i'm at the center of everything
that happens to me at scp-5049 the skin
salesman demon dan's discount homunculus
depot for more explorations into the
hearts of genuinely unnerving scps